Speaker 1: We will of course get to the DOJ
special counsel that has been announced. It is
starting all up again and I will tell you what
this likely means. But before we get to that,
I want to go to a completely bizarre, surreal clip
of a loser Republican gubernatorial candidate from
Arizona, Carrie Lake. She was at Mar a Lago for
some kind of event and she made a declaration,
she says, that she is going to fight what happened
in Arizona. Now, you know, and I know that what
happened in Arizona is she lost? What happened
in Arizona is the other candidate, Katie Hobbs,
got more votes. And when things work as planned,
the candidate who gets more votes. Becomes the
governor. Very difficult concept apparently for
Kerry Lake. Listen to this. And she got the hero's
welcome and she said we were going to fight.
Speaker 2: This started the incredible Kerry like.
They had to do everything they
could to stop us ballot harvesting.
Speaker 1: Yeah, they had the vote.
Speaker 2: They had to shut down the
machines on election day. But we
know their tricks and they think
they can slow and pour cold water on a movement.
Speaker 1: Now I want you all to understand, she
says, what they did was ballot harvesting. And to
what was the word she said, turn off or slow down.
Speaker 2: They had to do everything they
could to stop us ballot harvesting. They
had to shut down the machines on Election Day.
Speaker 1: Right. So the issue she's citing that
has some substance is that there was an issue
at a few Maricopa County locations because of
a couple of malfunctioning machines. The
machines were fixed. And the Republican
Party originally filed the lawsuit, dropped
their lawsuit because it was all taken care of,
did not substantively affect the election ballot.
Harvesting is just something they repeat. I don't
even think they know what it means.
Speaker 2: But we know their tricks
and they think they can slow and pour cold
water on a movement. It is not possible,
people. You cannot stop the American spirit.
You cannot stop the founding fathers.
Speaker 1: One person is clapping.
Speaker 2: And the blood that we have that we have
inside of us. And so I will fight. What happened
on Tuesday of what was it two weeks ago now?
Where are we? Two weeks in. We vote for a month
in Arizona. We count both votes for two weeks.
And look, it's a joke. Our our elections
are a circus run by clowns. I'll tell you.
Speaker 1: I love that we are going to fight. What
happened? What does that even mean? You just lost.
How do you fight the fact that you lost by lying
and claiming that you won. So don't for a second.
I don't want. I know most people in my audience
would never fall for something like this.
Don't even allowed to enter your brain that
anything other than Katie Hobbs becoming the
governor is going to happen in Arizona. Now, maybe
Carrie Lake is going to fight this by running for
governor again in the future if she's not Trump's
VP, which she wants to be, and we'll get to that
a little bit later. But all that happened is
that she lost and she wants to fight that.
I don't think she's going to be successful.